this isn't an original paper this is
just
a report yeah this is a science news
article
published this week so in science
vaccine trials ramp up in children
adolescence
and let's see there's um there's a quote
here
if memory serves here we go um adult
deaths from covet 19 dwarf those in
children
in the united states for example young
people make up about 250 of 500
000 total deaths but for children coven
19 is still
quote causing more deaths than influence
it does in a typical season
says douglas dickema a pediatrician and
bioethicist at seattle children's
hospital quote
those are unnecessary deaths and should
be prevented
so i i found this uh report a bit
upsetting
um not only so first of all to say
it still causes more deaths than
influenza in a given year
a turns out to be questionable so i've
got that link here yeah you want to
show that um so again i just i did not
spend any time here so i just i went and
looked at
the cdc on influenza and
um this is oh boy uh so
in the 2019-2020 influenza season
there were 188 reported pediatric flu
deaths
and that was a fairly high year
apparently but you scroll down
and you find that
um again you like i was not ready for
this
um oh here we go well any death in a
child from a vaccine preventable illness
is a tragedy
the number of pediatric flu deaths
reported to cdc each season is
likely an undercount for example even
though the reported number of deaths
during the 2017-18 flu season was 188
cdc estimates that turns out to be the
same number i think this year
cdc estimates the actual number was
closer to 600.
it is likely the actual number of
children who died from flu during the
2019-2020 season is higher as well
and i would say this is you know based
on no data
but that given the ways that cova deaths
have been counted
that i think if there is an error in
attributing
deaths to covit and children it's the
other way
it's an over count and the cdc is
telling us that they think that deaths
attributable to flu in children
is reliably an undercount and if those
two even if those things
aren't true those two numbers of deaths
so far from covet and deaths this last
year from
uh flu and children are so close that
you would at least need to do a
statistical analysis
and um you know this this claim from
this pediatrician and bioethicist
um that it's it's higher higher deaths
in covid
in children from covert than from flu is
suspect
at best and the idea that we are making
policy based on this
policy which involves vaccinating
children
is scary yeah not only making policy
um but doing so in
um in a way that has hidden hazards that
aren't discussed here
so actually zach would you put up the
graph that i sent you
so this is also um cdc in origin this is
2019 2018 2019 and you can see there
that the number of flu deaths in
zero to four is at two
can you read it yeah it's 250 266 2016.
but then 5 to 17 is 211.
so i don't know you know i don't know
what the children demarcation is for
covid but um certainly it's over four
right now so that's that's a bigger
number than
we were seeing right now go back to the
uh the
report the science news article yeah the
science news article
okay now unfortunately do you want zak
to show this yeah you can show it and
scroll up unfortunately
i can't see it there but i believe
that the numbers here
so i saw wasn't here
this is embarrassing but they had a
deaths um in the zero to 20
range and by saying zero to zero to 20
years old
years old exactly um i can't find it
there
but it creates a bias because
effectively what we've got
is evidence that very young children are
pretty well protected and that the
numbers are very low
what they're not saying here and what
troubles me
is that okay first of all it's
manipulative
to say any these deaths are preventable
and any is too many
right coming out against the death of
children is
you know not uh
it is a position that everybody will uh
embrace and many will
strongly do so on an emotional basis no
but it
it at best pretends and at worst no it
best
doesn't understand and at worst pretends
that tradeoffs don't exist
right exactly and so there is reason to
keep
children away from these vaccines that
comes from the fact that they
by virtue of their age are very well
protected
from catching and uh apparently
transmitting and transmitting
and suffering bad outcomes right and
they've got the most of their lives to
live to experience what we hope are no
but might be long-term side effects of
these new vaccines that's exactly it not
only do they have more of their lives
ahead of them in which bad
outcomes could emerge imagine outcomes
that are delayed 30
or 40 years right if you're 50 and you
get
a vaccine that has a delayed bad outcome
right you may not live to experience it
or it may not
compromise much of your life but if
you're young of course um
it will but um but the other thing
is developmental right
the question is what is the age at which
it is
most reasonable to start vaccinating
right now you and i
in dealing with vaccinations for our
children and we did fully vaccinate them
but we had a rubric which was to delay
each of the vaccinations as long as
possible
so that we would get the full protection
of those vaccine there was no point in
vaccinating kids against things that
they weren't going to encounter
so we vaccinated them at the point that
an encounter with the pathogen was
likely
and we delayed we delayed travel you
know the reason part of the reason that
i was doing study abroad
alone for many years when i was just
driven to do it and i wanted you to be
part of it and our children to be part
of it
and you know you really pushed back
against it and said they're you know yes
lots of people live in these places but
you know we're we're not going to put
our children in the situation where we
have to choose between exposing them to
diseases
and vaccinating them earlier than um
than we think they should be vaccinated
and so
we didn't take them for instance to you
know the
ecuador and amazon until we felt they
were old enough to get the full
you know yellow fever and all the rest
of the vaccinations that they really we
felt they needed to have in order to be
safe there
right so okay we're going to vaccinate
kids
who are better protected are more are
going to have
likely to have greater impacts both
because of the amount of time and
because of the early stage in their
development at which they're
encountering these vaccines which open
up possibilities
for bad outcomes that adults won't have
and at the same time in that article it
describes the fact that because we have
pretty good data
from the uh the safety trials that have
already been done these trials are being
scaled back in terms of the number
right so basically this is being treated
as pro forma which is exactly the
opposite of a
responsible approach to this the
responsible approach would say
kids have less to gain and more to lose
we should be
very sure about the safety and then we
should figure out what the age is rather
than
clumping people zero to twenty right
which is crazy because you know
kids 18 19 do have some substantial risk
so anyway the the elephant in the room
of course
is the perverse incentive surrounding
the profitability of vaccinating
everybody
and so i increasingly think we have to
worry about what role that is playing
yeah it does not make sense to me maybe
somebody will explain to us
why uh why we don't get it but it
doesn't make sense to me that all of the
people who definitely had covid
and i understand there's a problem with
people who may have had covet right but
people who definitely had covid they've
had the equivalent of a vaccine
and it's not obvious that this couldn't
compromise immunity in ways that we
discussed last time
or at the very least be needless and
expose them to risks that we can't
say much about because they could be
very well delayed and we haven't seen
the outcomes here so
at the level of a desire to vaccinate
everyone as if vaccination is inherently
good and the more people we can get it
to the better
that does not pay proper heed to the
fact that the cost benefit
analysis is very different depending
upon who you
are and that means we should be hedging
out those risks
for several different groups of people
exactly and those yeah the
the three populations that i've
mentioned multiple times are you you've
already mentioned two of them it's
children
it's people who've already had covet and
it's pregnant women yep
absolutely yeah
you